ganz aktuell erreicht uns dieses video
ist fallen schüsse heute morgen in köln
im stadtteil marienburg mehrere
maskierte täter bremsen einen
geldtransporter aus beschießen ihn als
sich die türen nicht wie geplant öffnen
anschließend sollten sie wohl eines
ihrer flucht fahrzeuge an und dieses
video wurde hier von einem passanten
offensichtlich aufgenommen und liegt uns
exklusiv vor wir sehen einen blauen
renault sie wechseln dann später in
einen dunklen mercedes vito sollen
diesen blauen renault angezündet haben
verschwinden schlussendlich in
unbekannter richtung hier sehen wir den
brennenden renault ob und wie viel beute
die flüchtigen gemacht haben es wird zur
stunde noch ermittelt die verhandlungen
und die spurensicherung am tatort laufen
dass hier die erschütternden bilder
heute vormittag aus köln marienburg der
brennende fluchtwagen der täter die hier
einen geldtransporter überfallen haben
ihn geschossen haben und dazu das
passende video und für uns vor ort in
köln ist jetzt unser reporter-team
specks dem nach bild -informationen
sollen die täter maschinengewehre gehabt
haben gibt es verletzte was kannst du
uns aktuell sagen
nach den ersten erkenntnissen die sich
auch vor ort sammeln konnten zum
beispiel anhand der hülsen haben die
täter auf jeden fall mit
maschinengewehre benutzt und so wie es
aussieht waren das wohl auch aka 740
darauf weist zumindest die hülsen die
hier am tatort liegen verletzte gibt es
zum glück keine die beiden
geldtransporterfahrer die wurden nicht
verletzt das ist eigentlich ein wunder
denn die können ja mag auf den
geldtransporter schauen denn da vorne
sieht man man hat ein wir haben das eben
mal gezählt sechs einschusslöcher die
relativ mittig auf der windschutzscheibe
gelandet sind möglicherweise wollte man
da tatsächlich nur ein bisschen
erschrecken die menschen denn sonst
hätte man vielleicht
richtung 17 geschossen das weiß man
natürlich alles nicht die wichtigste
nachricht ist tatsächlich die dass die
beiden geldtransporterfahrer hier
unverletzt rauskommt und ja alles andere
müssen jetzt die ermittlungen dass man
zeigen was weiß man zur stunde über die
täter
ja es waren wohl mehrere täter die
offenbar das sieht man ja in dem video
auch das ganze minuziös vorbereitet
haben die sind eben in zwei autos
mindestens hier angekommen haben vorne
mit einem schwarzen mercedes video vito
den geldtransporter ausgebremst sind
dann ausgestiegen haben dann
gleichzeitig auch schon den blauen
renault clio die ende da hinten sehen in
brand gesteckt das heißt das ganze war
auf jeden fall wohl geplant es waren
mindestens zwei drei täter wie viele es
genau waren das wird man sich jetzt
erstmal herausfinden müssen verkehrs
kameras vielleicht die täter sind auch
noch flüchtig sind natürlich schwer
bewaffnet deswegen läuft die fahndung
natürlich auch auf hochtouren